[Music]
we are it's happening
all of our all of our enemies are going
to prison
bro I know awesome I know Reckoning I
think this is a pizza wrecking Papa
warned us though dude it's like the Q
Anon storm but actually the reverse
like the Q Anon storm was supposed to
like you know take away all the
pedophiles or whatever well I guess it
is yeah yeah I guess it is doing that so
wait before we get too deep so Hassan's
dog Kaya's here this is true and my dogs
are downstairs waiting to be
uh brought up but I wanted to film it so
can someone go grab Ela
sure
I should go stand out there this is our
dog's meeting
oh I'll I'll grab Tire let's see
sometimes it's better just to let him
let him off
someone's gonna bring you up all right
I'm gonna go sit you guys have a boom
over there yes
[Music]
I think it might be better if she's off
the leash when they meet she gonna go
like she'll go crazy
I mean I'll take her off leash but I'm
just saying she'll go crazy let's see if
she'll do tricks for the camera I want
to see right now she's over stimulated
so it's really hard but
I went in I literally got one of these
like training bags because I'm so
[__] Opie okay
sit
good girl shake
Gaia Shake good girl good [__]
other hand no that's a good lay down
okay that's uh no but it's not the right
command though it's not argument
up get up come on up
oh good girl
okay here lay down
good girl good job
here let's see who's the toughest one
roll over roll over roll over
roll over
yay okay we'll go back
go back
good girl
that's that's pretty much it and then
she has the
I mean then I I mean I know she knows
weight
and then she knows look at me
like if you do like a noise you're just
like distract her
okay look at me yeah she's not very good
at that guy look at me
look at me
go girl good girl we're still working on
it we work on it every day
I have a dog trainer that I talk to
about like what to do and I'm eventually
gonna onboard her with him but um you
know he's just like he tells me that I
need to like make her work for her food
so usually I train her with like
Here Comes crazy dogs
look there's another dog here
I just wanna let him off the leash
this is a great idea guys okay
yeah Alfredo is crazy
[Music]
true
[Applause]
her down first but it's too late now
yeah she's so cute
[Music]
she's already socialized with other dogs
she's very friendly it's not like an
issue
okay
oh she gets scared too oh that's okay
that's very nice guys no it's good it's
good to put the fear of God in there
she's so nice there you go good good
okay we're all friends
oh she's so soft oh my God you smell
terrible though inside of her ears I
gotta get her groomed
in the front
she's cuter
can the camera go up front no
no it can't go that far
okay Alfredo's doing good let's let them
say hi
good boy Alfredo goodbye I thought it
was gonna be the one that was gonna be
chill
y
Alfredo so good and then when Alfredo
came into a picture Shredder became a
psycho
Alfredo's a street dog good boy
she's so nice
this is how Shredder Behavior against me
at first too yeah just you're just
protecting the turf
saying I'm the hard drive of the podcast
Shredder
you really want to start beef with that
dog yeah
we have no baby manners
Alfredo's so nice shredder what's up
with you
come on
there you go Kaya that's cute
look at this Precious Moment she's very
she's very dark brother why are you
being so crazy
stop it
Alfredo wants to play yeah good
Playhouse
it's better what what is going on chill
she's being so sweet
such a little [__] normally
like actually alphaing her a little bit
because she literally will like she
takes my bro my brother is a very
submissive dog
um she's super well trained but she's
just like it's not in her personality to
be like aggressive
and Kyle will literally like hump her
and stuff like
yeah she's just like will straight up
dominate this like five six year old dog
all the time it's very annoying
try to put that down yeah 100 percent
Trevor has no idea how big that dog's
gonna be yeah he doesn't want to start
beef at the dog bark he would he would
beef with any yeah yeah
he jumps at their face she's pooping
she's pooping get a shot get a shot
dude look what Shredder did to me
or I don't know if it was alfredo or
Shredder that's
all over you yeah
yeah we got [__]
good boy big ass poop too [__]
oh all my training efforts it's all good
yeah
I just took a human-sized [__] on the
ground I think
I think what would be good is if um
somebody took them
I think um it would be good for them if
they all went out together
it was me yeah that couldn't have been
Kaya she's a perfect little angel she
would never do anything wrong did you
get a shot of that look at that [__]
human-sized [__] dude I don't know get a
shot of that poop you probably shouldn't
show poop right just dog [__] what are
you talking about I don't know I don't
know if YouTube cares YouTube's like
don't show dog [__] that's weird
it's educational
[Music]
yeah try to take them all outside I
think that'll be nice because I think
the problem is that this is Shredder's
turf
that'd be great if if Hassan doesn't
Hassan doesn't say she doesn't have
Oliver vaccine just take them in the
parking lot yeah that's a neutral ground
Alfredo you look happy
yeah Shredder used to be the coolest dog
with other dog shredders stop dude was
your product Shredder damn
you guys all go outside you guys all go
outside
[Music]
oh
all right and there they go
wow what a start
with the government best friends
Shredder's very he's become so Alpha
no it's good it's good she needs she
needs a little bit of an alpha dog in
her life all the dogs that she's
surrounded with that I socialize her
with
one can't keep up with her puppy energy
why is their paper towels over did she
pee as well
I think Justin no I think that just got
knocked over oh okay yeah
um all the dogs in our life have like
they're very submissive so she's
constantly dominating them and it annoys
the [__] out of me like I want her to be
I wanted to know her place like I can't
be the only one who's barking at her
okay there you go Shredder will put her
in there your dogs
huh you're a bark of your dogs like
actually a dog bark you do that oh yeah
on growl will you show us how what it
sounds like yeah I mean I like if she's
doing something that I don't like
literally and she's like I never heard
of that in the doggy Playbook
I got some I got some different
techniques I'm like Caesar Milan what
better do you uh not abusive you lick
her ear and stuff too
sometimes I bite her ear
I've never done anything weird with my
dogs they're they're gonna come in best
friends yeah but Shredder even as a pup
he when he went to the dog park he would
just um
I love that
I like that yeah it's a that's a lunch
pail fighter yeah
yeah
um but um okay there it is so okay
we did it folks bringer and every time
they're gonna be besties after today I'm
sure of it oh 100 is a this is a dog
cast now not a podcast that's great I
mean [__] I do this show four times a
week uh the dogs want to take over I'm
not gonna argue bro speaking of dog
walking what did you do yesterday you
were never defeating the you are never
defeating the like you claim to be an
anti-misogynist and you just eviscerated
a woman on camera like scorched Earth
yeah it was pretty interesting
conversation wasn't it
yeah yeah it sure was I love those I
mean every time you do one of those it's
great I'm like this is free content for
me yeah I'm glad yeah I think people are
starting to enjoy it you know I'm sure
one of these days I after that was over
I was like I guess it was okay that's
happened the past few times where I
wasn't like I guess but I guess in the
end it did go pretty good and uh you
know what I feel like
I feel like when you first
talk to Stephen Crowder and then he did
the same Cedar what a [__] nightmare
moment which ended up you know having a
domino effect on Stephen Crowder's life
that led to his untimely divorce
and the fact that he was abusive came
out
and he dropped a million dollars he
dropped a 50 million dollar uh contract
very publicly remember when you did all
that Stephen Crowder yeah back then you
were not very confident in your debating
skills so I feel like now you've like
gone back like it's an anime right you
went over you went against the boss that
you thought you were not powered enough
for that's true yeah and then he went
back and you started first slaying like
goblins and rats and dungeons it was the
first one was it the first one was the
next of the reason Nexium yeah it was
the Nexium thing and I wanted to say I
think that's why you you feel it's like
your first high you'll be chasing
forever uh because that was such a
unique circumstance of him not knowing
anything about you and walking into it
and you like got to play along and
pretend like you and the interesting and
the Tourette's thing yeah you're not
gonna get another one of those for a
while that's that's yeah
only London one was good because I I
loved that I had the lunch box that was
a pretty good twist yeah and the Ali
London one was also probably your like
most
skilled
interlocutor yet I think your most
skilled foe I can't believe I'm saying
this but like if you're oh he is he's
pretty slick yeah when you when you talk
to like professional transphobes it's
like talking to a flat earther like you
they have a different set of facts
they're going to operate off of those
facts you need to know everything about
that and you know
um after that I felt like the the Pearly
girl thing was not as like
like she was just eviscerated from I
thought she'd be more prepared I thought
so frankly me too A lot of people were
saying she thought they thought she was
maybe on something I didn't even yeah I
thought she was zooted I I thought she
was just straight barred out the entire
time she was like this is boring
um
I don't know what the [__] that was
about why was she doing I didn't I don't
know I don't think she was on anything I
think she was just just like you're
training for debates maybe I thought
just like you're training for debates
maybe she's training to be like a
disappointed housewife uh like she's
just you know she's doing oh she's gonna
be yeah she's doing box wine and bars
and like you know just like one hand
doing laundry that's why she looks so
tired I think I think she loves you with
one hand cleaning with the other I think
she'd love that opportunity but I mean
one of my favorite moments was when I
asked her to rate herself by her own
metric oh dude she tells me she goes I
think that this is uh not a fair
conversation I said excuse me
that was what you do
uh but um no when she said she was a
five
I was like yeah oh I buy her own metric
though oh no that's sad right because
like when you meet your soul
your your life partner you don't want to
be like well listen I'm a five you're a
five this is just not gonna be that cool
yeah we're we're gonna we're gonna yeah
we're gonna have a mid-off like be happy
with yourselves man what the [__] that's
our marriage there's Shredder just a
battle of mid
there's kayaks
um you can let her off she has a better
if she's off
she has a toy a chew toy as well
somewhere there's Alfredo and Kaya who
are best friends Alfredo's best friends
Alfredo you're the best man
you want you want Kai to be obvious but
I'm telling you she's a menace dude she
will eat all the cables and [__] well
Olivia
your job today and I know you're gonna
hate this
you got to be glued to Kaya at all times
that is so easy to do that when he was a
puppy just chewing cables
I just like I don't even care about like
the the damage of the cables they just
don't want her like picking up that
habit you know about the damage to our
property yeah
because like dude I she is like constant
round-the-clock surveillance 24 7. uh
when I'm streaming she's in the pen
behind me
I'm like you know I'm juicing her with
like treats and and different like brain
stimulating things I walk her multiple
times in the day to like get her to pee
outside you know I just puppy training
is hard yeah it's really really really
hard for me dude I I had eczema for the
first time in my life I have eczema yeah
I've never started yeah contact
dermatitis or whatever I don't know I
think I got some of that recently too
for them on my [__] face I've never
oh that's the worst yeah yeah I've never
had it before in my entire life I've
never been allergic to anything in my
entire life I thought I was allergic to
her because she's shedding like crazy
right now I was deaf in one ear for 24
hours it's like plugged up yeah huh it
was crazy I just went to the
dermatologist and like they have [__]
that makes it go away like immediately
yeah I did I did the [__] solution
and then I sat there on the pillow for
like 10 minutes okay and then they
sprayed it with like another solution
yeah and then pulled it out and it was
just crazy it was
you had your ear cleaned I was talking
about the eczema they went in there with
like a squirt gun yeah whoa I've seen
videos of that on Tick Tock I have one
you want to see did you see all the [__]
that came out yeah I want to see all the
[__] did you have a video of it I know
yeah but I didn't upload it I'm looking
I watch it okay I can show it to you in
private yeah well I put it on the
internet I mean I show there's a photo
of it on my alt account of like the gunk
afterwards but not the video let me see
because I've watched a lot of those I
could tell you how bad it is I'll grab
the photo I've seen some bad ones that
that [__] is nasty bro yeah it's just
like
I guess I don't know I guess it's just
part of becoming older where like I feel
like everything in my body used to run
on autopilot and now like I actually
have to make an effort to like fix stuff
you know what I mean oh here's some of
the gunk okay we have breaking oh my god
dude that's even grosser than my pesto
[__] which was in a similar ball I feel
like that's gross sir looks like algae
yeah do you think that's not as gross um
damn dude how does that happen
um I guess like your earwax builds up if
you don't clean it and then no you're
not supposed to clean it they always say
don't clean yeah I don't but uh I was in
the shower with Q-tips specifically so
how the [__] are you supposed to clean
it to prevent it yeah the way with like
a solution I think so what happened is I
was in the shower
and I thought like I would I thought I
could just get away with doing what I
always do oh I have water in my ear and
I went like you know what I mean yeah
and then I was like oh [__] I can't hear
now oh it must be because you know
there's water so I just started like
trying to get it out with the with the
traditional methods
didn't happen didn't work and it made it
worse and then I put a Q-tip in there
also made it worse I think I just like
kept pushing it in packing it in there
yeah this is this is so gnarly dude so
when you came out you could hear
everything dude I was hearing in [__]
4K it was weird I heard too much when I
when my left ear unlocked like when they
unplugged it
I realized I still already have some
[__] wax on the right ear because now
I was like oh [__] I can't hear as well
on the right ear as a matter of fact I
realized did you was it feel good to get
a flush oh my it feel it felt like an
orgasm no it's not it wasn't
uncomfortable at all I mean it's a
little uncomfortable but like oh skin no
she's getting into those cables on the
server thing we got cable uh
interference okay oh Olivia's went there
um he's on it Alfredo is just with Kaya
that is sweet
better what happened here
he's protecting his Turf he's just don't
worry about it
Hassan did you get dizzy when you did it
um not really I was sitting down so
maybe I might have been but I don't
remember I don't recall we should do it
Ethan
I do I mean I don't think my ears are
you know what I bought I bought one of
those little pens on Amazon that like
sucks it up it's like a vacuum with a
camera on it only 40 bucks and you have
like an iPhone app and the camera can
just like literally we had a similar
thing for the um blackheads for a
blackhead extractor that had like a
super close camera we did that on the
show a long time ago but that seems like
a good idea to do that yourself to go
all the way down into your ear with the
yeah yeah I would do that I can't tell
if you're being sarcastic or not no it's
probably terrible I gotta Steady Hand
what was that what was the conversation
we had about doctors and steady hands
they're supposed to have steady hands I
think no uh we have breaking news Jimmy
Lee's Instagram appears to have been
permanently banned no [__] way and
the way I just noticed this is that oh
I'll show you I went to my
DMS because I saw I had a new DM and it
just says Instagram user with no profile
picture can you take the earwax off the
screen please yeah that's just sitting
there for some reason and uh
Oh see now they're barking together dogs
that bark together ride together die
together
and then I scrolled up I was like oh
it's Jimmy Lee and then you go to the
the profile and boom this is
user Instagram user nothing is here I'm
gonna text them right now that's sad
so was it the racist post was it the
botting I just got off the phone with
him this morning he he brought nothing
up about this must have just happened
damn oh boy it was like uh half a
million followers with like the 12 likes
or something that's crazy yeah what
could what could have happened
yeah what how could this have happened
only three four five reasons I can
imagine I told him your silence on the
matter is deafening yeah you need to be
fighter
I'll try I'll do I'll reach out to
Instagram I'll do everything I can uh oh
Alfredo Kaya wants to play
you could play with Kai alfredo
I just text them
we might have to get him to call in
sorry Hassan this is transcends all of
them we haven't talked we haven't even
touched the dock yet yeah so there was
just a lot of things about Pearl like
the more I thought about it
I realized that the stuff she was saving
saying was making even less sense for
example she goes
men have to sign up for Selective
Service
therefore women shouldn't get the right
to vote unless they sign up for
Selective Service first of all
team occurred me at the time selective
service has nothing to do with the right
to vote if men don't sign up for
Selective Service they can still vote
yeah
it's got nothing to do with it yeah it's
I I don't know why that's like a new
meta in the in the Pua manosphere sphere
where they uh where they claim that it's
like men got the right to vote
because they could because they were
serving in combat and like a a an odd
historic reference as a matter of fact I
believe because
um I think after World War one they uh
decreased the voting age to 18 from 21
because those were the people that were
getting drafted to go to World War One
okay yeah so or is it was it after World
War II I think it was two but it might
have been World War II but but it's
hilarious because like like black people
were
black people did not have the right to
vote and they were still being drafted
also the draft ends at what 35 so does
that mean people over the age of 35
cannot vote like there's so many issues
well this concept there's so much of my
time alcohol in which case alcoholics
can't serve by the way she was an
alcoholic drug users uh people in
wheelchairs people with flit uh what the
[__] is it that Trump got out for bone
spurs bone spurs cannot vote I mean like
she doesn't
even think about the stuff she I don't
think she thinks about much which is
what I found out after watching this gay
people apparently can't a vote if you go
back far enough yeah don't ask don't
tell don't ask don't vote you want to
know what's funny in Turkey there's
actually a very specific circus
mandatory draft for uh mandatory service
for everyone like all men yeah oh yeah I
know that about turkey actually yeah
it's uh high school graduates or uh if
you go to college college graduates get
a short and sent uh like like an officer
program basically uh it's not like the
ROTC officer program it's still pretty
[__] gruesome but
um
the the mandatory sentence goes from I
think like two years back in the day was
two years to like it's cut in half to
one year if you go to college anyway
um one way to get out of military
service is by proving your homosexuality
that's awesome and uh well how do you
prove your homosexuality you can't just
like say you're gay gay and send them a
video no literally oh for real no back
in the day it was called a pink slip
back in the day you had to go and show
these medical examiners like a board of
medical examiners that you're gay and
you can't be a top they would not
consider topping another man
you had to be a bottom you have to send
them a video of you getting photos to be
analyzed by medical professionals I'm a
boss okay what about blow jobs it has to
be like anal penetration I think it was
yeah I think you have to be topped wow I
would do that to get out of the military
though yeah I mean that's it easy
that's easy
you know but okay there it is she's
actually been coping pretty hard but we
can we can get in that tomorrow
uh we've got a lot to talk about today
but you're going to Japan so we won't
have an episode next week
uh our last week's episode was canceled
because I thought I might have covet I
don't
I'm just checking congratulations
congratulations I can't believe you were
in a wait you were in a room with like
someone with code I was in a tiny room
with my lawyer for nine hours and he
called me the next morning and said I
just tested positive
bro you're I thought I'd get it you're
undefeated that I mean well I have had
covered no I but that's what I mean like
you're undefeated these conservatives
are nothing on you dude you [__]
you're vaccinated you're like triple
vaccinated yeah you're you had covid you
were literally you stared covered down
the barrel of the gun of coven we didn't
and you [__] yeah and you prevailed
dude I'm very glad I didn't get coveted
that would have been such a [__]
nightmare and you know I'm not trying to
get coveted twice three times I'm not
trying to get involved in that long
covet stuff that I've been hearing about
you know yeah no thanks not great
oh yeah so ah there's so much good Pearl
[__] I know like the dangerous jobs
narrative which is one of my favorites
because it's like yeah notoriously
[__] CEOs uh the most dangerous job
of all is like heavily dominated by men
hey what guys don't it's better to keep
them off the leash
um yes
wait she's taking him where
oh that's not that bad
but but if they're hanging out they
should be off the leash otherwise the
leash makes them act crazier
okay yeah that's cool yeah
uh so you got some Teddy fresh dog stuff
or no
I don't think anything her size it's all
for like small dogs oh I don't know why
that is when you look at all this stuff
it's all it's like the Discrimination
that I receive from Teddy fresh on a
daily basis is
unheard well have you thought about
shopping at like uh the big boy xxxl Big
Mad Dog big dog story yeah she's not
even a big girl yet no for you well for
me that yeah that's what I have to do
it's literally
it's literally all I have to do as a
matter of fact bat and Tall yeah
well I oh God so she immediately went on
her uh show
after our live stream now if you guys
don't recognize who this is he went
viral for he was talking with uh Molina
where he was like you should just stay
in a relationship endure yeah endure if
you're getting abused and I was like
first of all this [__]
that he does not have a wife right if he
did she's under she's under the rafter
somewhere brother all of these
podcasters like wifeless childless I
don't know what are you doing
um I think he's divorced oh no I'm
guessing I don't know if that's true but
he said
someone asked do you think it's worse
for uh the kids to have their parents
get divorced or to see their mom get
beat up and he says oh divorce no
question
yeah and uh I asked her that question
thinking about him and she's like it's
such a stupid question
I don't even know how to answer it I was
like okay great so anyway she goes and
talks to him and check out this take
it's so great
[Music]
impressionable young men who are just
sitting at home and like what did I do
like a lot of these young guys this is
an american-centric thing but a lot of
young white guys are feeling bad for
being white I know they're just like
yeah you're bad because you're white
like dude
Spencer and I'm like 17 and I'm like
Call of Duty yes bro this is literally
loser Behavior you're like training
these
uh supposedly young man which I don't
even think young men are watching these
[__] I think it's like old
divorced dads who are like yeah that's
right that's what he's do they're doing
that to young man you're right like but
even if let's say in the in the
hypothetical scenario that there are
actually young men watching these guys
you're just literally training them to
be sad pathetic [__] losers dude
that's one of the questions I kept
asking is like what is so you're telling
women that they're aging out and that uh
they need to set their standards down
and
what is the message what is the point of
sharing this message and she goes I'm
just telling the truth it's like
okay so no point
anyway here he continues like the Matrix
and Matrix in the media what are they
pushing and that's the crazy thing like
I just got off a stream where they were
literally pushing that women should
sleep around as opposed to being virgins
and so awesome that way that she
characterize that
how about women do whatever the [__]
they want that's what I said I said it's
neutral the sleeping around thing it
could be good it could be bad it depends
on the people it depends on their
experience but anyway this is the best
part yeah like it's like what are you
pushing you're pushing for promiscuity
which isn't good for women yeah and it's
not and it's not good sorry I had gone I
was just gonna say the guy running that
stream is a fat loser who's getting
divorced by his wife what wait okay
that's the best I love it
my man is has lost so much weight but
they I'll always be fat that they'll
always have thank you but I'll always be
found you look good you look good you're
you're working at it I see it and I'm
not like once a fat guy always a fact
also secondly
I mean glass houses [__] it's
not like you got 10 body fat [__] are
you talking he looks a little thick no
he's definitely I I know he's overweight
too I know he's not like skinny I can
tell that I just don't get that what's
his name can you can you see if this is
calling other dudes bald okay it's like
bro you're bald you're bald
you're the baldest [__] on the
planet right now but so I guess this is
a thing I don't know where this started
but they oh I think maybe it was fresh
and fit where they fantasized that ela's
leaving me and they just keep saying it
oh no no coconut dude it's awesome it's
no it's a normal perfectly normal thing
for two adults to fantasize about
I mean it's it's like two things that I
am not really uh anymore I mean I'm not
that fat anymore all of our tree I
learned has higher BMI than me I have a
harp oh wait I don't have a higher
what's your BMI we we did this last I'm
244 now so it's what's your BMI because
I just found out what mine is recently
okay let's see 244 for six four
mine was like 30.
I I might be lower than you then now is
30 BMI fat
I know you guys don't get upset I'm just
saying oh it says if your BMI is 30 or
higher it falls in the opp range yeah if
I'm still obese body mass index six four
244 pounds oh you want to know what my
BMI is what is it
29.7
[__]
world beast together brother no I'm
under them right I'm right under here
dude well I'm not healthy weight though
come on I I don't feel obese anymore I
feel like overweight what's funny about
this oh it says 25 to 30 overweight yeah
I like that it says like 25 or 30
overweight like
I mean look I'm I don't have a six-pack
yet but I'm fairly close to it at this
point so it's that's what you need to
know about BMI BMI is
ridiculous CMI is everything
ridiculous it should not be your North
Star it's everything literally it says I
am the first thing I think of I mean
almost last thing I think of this
comment was really insightful and
interesting this is saying slave owners
were like Father figures to Slaves
people they bought has to be like a new
secret menu for item for racism yeah
it's I've heard I've heard the uh
I've heard the thing that some like old
school Southern races say where they'll
be like well you wouldn't it's actually
a lot like the people mistreating their
slaves like you wouldn't beat up your
tractor that you just bought and I was
like bro you're talking about a human I
would I treat my tractor good boy I
changed this all regularly I'll keep a
good eye on the wheel make sure they
ain't getting all rubbed down like
talking about a [__] human like that
you just compared to an inanimate object
also a tractor doesn't
uh have its opinion on opinions about
anything I tell you what my tractor tell
me he don't want to work today that's
going to be a problem
yeah good thing tractors are inanimate
objects uh that can't talk back because
you know these [__] love
[__] those things too I know dude she
was so close to saying and I almost
asked her
do you think
some slaves that were freed would were
better off with their masters she would
say yes she would she was right there
she was right there she was right there
yeah and my favorite part about those
racist Clips is like Nick Fuentes is
sitting next to her going
he's like no no no I just don't like
here's what I'll say here's what my main
takeaway was look at this guy I heard
all of yeah he's looking great he's
looking great fantasizing about you uh
getting a divorce um did you find out if
he's divorced
dude we're trying to find his name he
didn't find his name every clip of him
just calls him Mr and door I'm looking
girl doesn't link his wait is it not
this King Rich no that's somebody else
oh this guy just shows up he doesn't
even get credit what a loser all all I
was gonna say is this
um I've heard the talking points so many
times
wait sorry we're supposed to be him real
Troy Francis top comment thanks for
having me on great show that's good I
think that's another guess
no what I was gonna say is this
um
I think it's it's super easy to be a
pygmy like in the manosphere like a
pikmi girl pygmy pick me pick me yeah
why are you making fun of short people
sorry I don't know why I'm going down
yeah no he's he's a little insecure
because he sent me a text message uh
about how he's five nine
[__] my I sent you an image can you
send me an image I sent it to you guys
too if you want to pull it up because I
was at the doctor the other day yeah the
one that said you're five nine yeah pull
up five where are you even why are you
even saying five nine well it was five
nine no it wasn't it was five it was
five ten point nine nine nine nine nine
oh what the [__] bro okay right I just
saw the nine and I thought oh it's five
nine he's honest about his height you
say nobody's five eleven and I know what
you're gonna say but I'm telling you
it was
510.9999 I'm a firm believer that no
human is five eleven you're six foot or
you're five nine okay I'm six foot
look at this that's my height I think
that's not five eleven for the record I
just want to point in here I want to
point to something here this is called
medical fraud what you're doing right
now this is a HIPAA violation this is
medical fraud
Matt Walsh's producer did something
similar the other day when uh he lied to
one of the the trans Healthcare
Providers to try to get like a reference
letter from them this is not as evil but
you know
you're lying to your doctor about your
height it's a great show by the way no
they they know my exact height you're
lying to your doctor by your height and
honestly there are plenty of height
related illnesses that your doctor might
misdiagnose you with now sure oh that no
they took my height with like a laser
bro it's in the system that's like
scientific
you could cut a [__] angle on my Dome
it's so uh I I have a friend well it's
Ludwig he uh every year when he goes to
the DMV every time he has to get a new
license yeah he has increased his height
about it yeah he just lies about his
height he's increased by one inch every
year so what does he know he's gotten up
to like six three I think he's literally
like five eleven that's how awesome you
can lie about that okay he's not 511
though so how tall is he
all right let's get to the point
um oh my God someone said his name is
Modern Life dating and he has gotten
lifo and has a documentary on it
you got liposuction what a loser dude
wait I gotta know if he's divorced he's
got to be divorced he's giving mad
divorce energy anyway let's move on
let's see so Pearl yada yada yada
uh Trump is getting absolutely bodied
this week and it's okay so good he they
I did everything right and they are
dying right and they indicted me where's
that God I love him so much he's back
he's so back dude everything right and
they indicted me wait where's that clip
when it was like when he was talking
about like after his arraignment when he
went to like uh deliver a speech
in front of a crowd of adoring fans
um he he talked about Bill Clinton a
little bit he's like I really like Bill
Bill should have been more involved in
the Clinton campaign when they said I
won't go to Wisconsin I said no no I
didn't if Bill was there you would have
gone to Wisconsin and I was like that's
that is so Trump that's like old school
Trump right there just you know adding
random [__] for no reason to the
conversation I feel that we can talk
about Trump every episode now until the
election yeah it's gonna be a game
Busters here's Trump uh with this very
insightful complaint
let's see Hillary Clinton broke the law
and she didn't get indicted
Joe Biden broke the law and in many
other ways we're finding out was the
audio so [__] it's [__] on every it
was [__] at this press conference
except for the PBS one everything right
and they indicted me I did everything
right and they indicted me I love that
I love that and his fan base believes
that so
it's great it was that music I did
everything right on the high seas baby
[Music]
the guys were joking that he sounds like
a pirate I did everything right and they
indicted
I stole those documents fair and square
I gave Polly a cracker and he flew away
from me
sleepy Joe the last time I seen you I
was looking at your son's Jolly Roger
Xbox the spot on the golden toilet imma
be honest that makes him even cooler
yeah there's fire yeah no it's hard to
top that sick
he's God he is he's out of control so
let's let's look at his Greatest Hits
from the uh they they [__] indicted
him on his on his birthday
like uh I think yeah they they his
arraignment
happened a day before his birthday oof
wow there's a lot of Clips here these
all holy [__] I mean
I can I get recited by heart if you want
okay I literally I watched it every a
moment of it I'm I'm such a stand dude
because like this is the this is the
best Trump because like he doesn't
actually
he doesn't actually have any real power
like Trump is a television figure if he
had his like Twitter account and they
basically lied to him and told him he
was the president and they basically
lied to his like fan base and told him
he was the president he'd be the
greatest uh TV figure of all time yeah
as long as he doesn't have like actual
power and he's not like genuinely
cutting legislation or like passing
stuff or using the bully pulpit in that
and to great effect and controlling the
Republican party's machine uh to do his
bidding he's great he's entertaining
he's sassy he's catty he loves drama
he's telegenic and he's hot and I'll say
I'm not afraid he's got a fast number
yeah
oh you read the indictment though it's
it's quite bad it's so bad I think
the only yeah I mean his his audience
and Fox News and all those people are
just relying on the fact that you
haven't read it it is very bad it is
very very very bad they have his ass
nailed pretty much they got him dead to
rights and then on top of that they've
got the recording the audio recording of
him saying I know these are classified
and that's why I can't show them to you
or I shouldn't be showing them too yeah
he's like stay stay far ahead or show
them to you but from afar okay you know
what I gotta put him back in the uh
bathroom now uh where they're secure so
there's 37 there's 37 counts uh that
range from you know conspiracy
obstruction of justice all the way to
espionage right and the Espionage one is
probably the weakest one out of all of
the 37 but it doesn't really matter
because the 36 other charges are so
uh they're so open and shut and which
and each of them carry a sentence as
well yeah that they are I don't know how
his legal team which two of his lawyers
literally are also involved in the
investigation
happened they were accused well they are
so it's two different ones that you guys
are okay so two was a quit and then
there's the two that are involved yeah
yeah okay we're involved great to be his
lawyer no no two are involved but the
one that one of them that's involved uh
trustee he actually had to he he is also
the one that was let go oh okay he was
like Jim trustee I believe is the is
Rusty is the lawyer that his that's one
of the lawyers that he's talking about
so
I mean without you know without
complicating matters further
I'll just say it like this uh
Donald Trump has a very unique way of
doing crimes in the most like open and
honest way possible where certain things
that would be like rule breaks that you
normally wouldn't get punished for
basically turn into crimes that the
government has to prosecute
um because of the way he conducts
himself and in in any other circumstance
this document Saga would not be a real
issue I mean he's right Joe Biden
actually uh you know was was
investigated technically or
um was was cooperating with authorities
for extracting all of these documents
that uh that he was storing in his house
from all the way back from when he was a
Senator
um some of them were sent to a
university that part is all like super
above board super legal right uh same
with Mike Pence
a lot of people take back mementos from
office right but when the government
comes over and says hey we want those
back actually we want to check to see
which ones that these are like
potentially classified you say yes go
ahead go to all of my houses uh go to
all my warehouses where I store this
stuff and you can extract these
documents that's what Mike Pence did
that's what
uh that's what Joe Biden did that is not
what Donald Trump did Donald Trump for
some reason refused to cooperate with
the authorities at first it was a civil
uh case with Nara right he refused for
uh almost a year and then he uh he he
basically lied to the authorities on
numerous occasions claiming that he had
actually given back all of the documents
while he still maintained plenty of uh
classified documents that he had not
Declassified now in a normal situation
that's like kind of hard to prove right
because there was this entire hubbub
about well I can d i can declassify
documents with my mind but Trump being
Trump actually is on the record quite
literally admitting long after he was no
long after he was done being President
telling to uh staffers and also a
journalist
I have this document of attack plans
this is classified documents America's
attack Invasion plan for Iran like and
and this is insane this is actually him
revealing this information
specifically because he had a petty
squabble with uh they them General Mark
milley the woke General okay and it was
Mark milley who was apparently more
gung-ho about doing attacks than Donald
Trump and he's trying to prove that to
the people in the room so he basically
shows people with no uh with with
no secret service clearance or or no
classified document clearance uh these
classified documents that he openly says
are classified and then he says you know
I could have Declassified these
documents back when I was President I
didn't but you know I could have
which
makes this situation really funny
because all of a sudden there's like
three different instances where he
obstructed Justice and like lied to the
authorities he gave him a clean bill
where he said like look I gave you I
delivered all of it he lied to his
lawyers he asked his lawyers how close
them out to pluck some of the documents
out of the pile which is out there now
which is also illegal yeah and and
conspiracy but the lawyers did the pluck
hey that's insane no no no no they did
not right they did not so what did he do
he went to his valet nauda this other
guy the the bald yeah he has like a
butler like a personal Butler yeah rich
people call them ballets
um no didn't know that so
he had his personal Butler extracted
documents he lot he first he instructed
his lawyers the lie to the authorities
the lawyers were like no just give the
[__] documents back he also
personally hated that his lawyers were
taking notes he was like Roy Cohn never
took notes in my meetings why are you
taking notes and of course lawyers are
supposed to take notes shouts out the
legal eagle for that one
um so
these notes were subpoenaed because
there is only one instance where
attorney-client privilege can be revoked
and that is if your lawyer is assisting
you in a crime that you are being
investigated or potentially a future
crime so this was the one instance where
the attorney-client Privileges is
legally revoked they signed off on it so
they got access to these notes and they
found out that Donald Trump had asked
his lawyers to pluck the documents uh
asked his lawyers to lie to the
authorities and then it gets even
funnier like I said he gives his Butler
the directives to sidestep his lawyers
and his legal team and he lied to his
legal team and he got his Butler to
extract some of these documents in
height and that was Butler's gonna go to
jail probably now his Butler's gonna go
to jail too
they didn't I did everything
right
that's the real question here because
I think that makes this story all the
more the motivation is very open like I
don't understand because again like you
pointed out he ignored two requests and
then finally he ignored a subpoena
why is he so dead set on keeping these
documents that's a great question one of
them by the way it has like America's
nuclear vulnerabilities I mean these are
like top top top most sensitive
documents there are
I don't know why because that sounds
sick as [__] to have that yeah do you
really think that's why I I do I do in
my heart of hearts I believe that Donald
Trump Rudy check this out the silos on
Montana they're totally vulnerable
Donald Trump wanted to show this to
every [__] dentist in South Florida
yeah and that's literally why he kept
them I'm almost certain of it but he
fought so hard and check this out Mike
the side the nuclear silos they're
running a Windows 98 it's ridiculous I'm
not even kidding here's why here's what
is exactly that here's why I believe
this
he showed North Korea or Iran attack
plans to kid [__] rock dude yeah
wait how do we know what's good wrong so
Kid diddler Rock because Kid Rock went
on Tucker Carlson's show and was like
Donald Trump is like showing me these
[__] attack plans and I'm sitting
there thinking I'm Kid Rock should I see
this like grandpa I haven't seen that I
wanna I need to pull that up right now I
got you Kid diddler Rock like had access
to America's attack
yeah you know how like Charles
entertainment cheese is like Chuck E
cheese he is like the middle name Kid
Rock has a middle name diddler okay kid
did The Rock right because of the lyric
because of the I call it they call it
statutory I call it mandatory yeah
oh grandpa calm down from the famous uh
the PG-13 movie Osmosis Jones soundtrack
by the way dude why have I not seen this
clip this is fantastic
um
is okay here we go oh Tucker loves it
better than that but then it comes out
right yeah isn't there stuff you want to
show like Jimmy Lee you know what I mean
think about it like that Jimmy Lee would
be the guy that Trump is showing yeah
Trump has his own like Legion of Jimmy
Lee that he's like constantly
surrounding I mean he's one of them
Jimmy is literally one of them isn't he
a member of one of his clubs yeah he
usually has multiple photos with him
yeah oh my God Jimmy Lee I wonder what
kind of classified documents he saw plus
Instagram was deleted at a suspicious
time oh you think he's involved plus Jim
uh I've been texting him he's begging
for your help um wait what did he say
he's he's distraught and he's going
bonkers and I'm like we're here to help
you we'll figure it out should we get
him on the call tomorrow tomorrow but um
he got an email saying your account has
been suspended so I don't know if it's
been permaband or what tell him to put
all of his notes together we'll talk to
him tomorrow okay tell him to also
figure out what kind of classified
documentary but his mom what I was gonna
say is he was on Newsmax Jimmy like did
a whole thing on news but that's right
he did I forgot about that he's a good
man though he's going to do a whole
stand-up set in our live show
it's gonna be great anyway here's Kid
Rock anything better than that but then
it comes out it's very it's reworded and
more political and like you know
politically correct and I'm like just
being we're looking at Maps I'm like you
know I'm like am I supposed to be like
[Laughter]
what do you think we should do about
North Korea I'm like what
right I don't think I'm qualified to
answer it no you barely qualified to
play the guitar dude dude Kid diddler
Rock man he had [__] North Korean
attack plans right in front of him tell
me what you think should we invade
he was over there being like come on
Donald what are we going to do about
this age of consent law [__] dude come
on let's lower it let's lower it Donald
I say it's statutory but me and you both
know it's mandatory it's mandatory what
are we gonna do about that
so okay there's Trump he's having a
great week he's he's crushing it on all
accounts uh here's the video I was
trying to pull up yeah but my The
Comeback the the indictment if you read
it is insanely detailed and insanely
damning I mean I don't think a single
person could actually read that and be
like Oh yeah this is overblown no he's
[__] I do want to personally say I am
in support of leakers uh and and you
know people who mishandle National
Security [__] like great do it yeah boy
I'm a fan
uh but this is very similar to the The
Da the Jack taharia situation like the
National Guard who wanted to groom his
little Discord kittens and was like
leaking top secrets from like a couple
months ago yeah right he just wanted to
show off he just wants to groom his
little dog okay
[__] full-blown adult dentist Jimmy
Lee he wanted to show the [__] to Jimmy
Lee
great Point man if Epstein was alive he
would have blackmailed the [__] out of
him with this he's like Epstein's like
yo show me those documents indicted me
no Epstein she's like yo show me those
okay
capability okay now show me the document
about the uh the tunnels uh that are
under Iran that we've been building for
the last 20 years for an invasion okay
okay okay take a picture of those
right there Jeffrey knows that already
see I have to say he already knows all
that well he knew because he's dead all
right yeah he was murdered
rest in peace to the goat
maybe not restaurants uh they're
inappropriate racial sexual or political
content on our children
[Applause]
image of this guy just caring so much
about trans people ruining children yeah
you know [__] me bring out the second
dinner course I didn't say that in fact
I didn't say that yeah they're they're
grooming our they're grooming our
daughters I should be the one grooming
them what the [__]
they don't want to [__] me no more they
want to do other gay stuff I don't like
they come to school they come home
talking about I shouldn't be touching
them and all that kind of what the [__]
is that I'll teach my kids
why'd I give my birth why'd I give birth
to my daughters if I can't you know
harass her friends Grandpa's funeral
keep telling her bring them around bring
them around bring them sexy ones around
I don't want these kids knowing what
sexual assault that kind of Kill My Vibe
frisky today yeah
yes standing oh can't even enjoy my Bud
Light no longer
huh
standing over the big guy the saddest
most pathetic [__] losers dude how
many people feel about that you see I'm
talking about cutting taxes people go
like that talking about talk about
transgender everyone goes crazy yeah
five years ago you didn't know what the
hell it was right very astute
observation to be honest yeah no it
makes you think makes you think really
great observation Trump is so [__]
good at just like literally telling
any group of people that he's talking to
that they're [__] dumbasses and have
them clap for it like a bunch of [__]
cackling hyenas like he literally just
said it he's like you guys are such
[__] idiots all you care about is
trash [__] he's five years ago nobody
knew what it was Trump ran on being
literally the most LGBT friendly
Republican when people forget that they
asked him during the North Carolina
bathroom Bill Saga which ironic he's
literally in North Carolina there
um when that was actually uh that was a
major misstep because every corporation
was like [__] you we're pulling out of
we're pulling our business out of North
Carolina if you don't fix this trans
bathroom Bill he literally said keep it
the way it is what are you doing
verbatim and then they said okay Caitlyn
Jenner which bathroom uh can she use
he's like as long as she's in Trump
Tower she can use any bathroom she wants
I don't care
that wasn't that long ago it wasn't that
long ago when he was waving a [__]
lgbts for Trump flag and the reason why
I show this the reason why I talk about
this is not necessarily to say Trump is
an ally obviously not but uh he reads
the room very well and the the the
environment dramatically shifted over
the course of such a short period of
time where this became the prominent
message and Republicans are that
susceptible to propaganda that easily
manipulated it's bananas there's no such
thing they don't have real issues it's
all culture worse all right let me let
me just catch you guys up so Donald
Trump was arraigned in Miami here he is
in court pleaded not guilty to 37
criminal charges related to mishandling
of classified documents his aide Walt
was also arrested and booked but did not
enter a plea the judge ordered that
Trump could not communicate with naota
about the case oh that'll be that'll be
oh no he already dude dude he Walt naura
has been going everywhere with him in
public very openly in that not in the
North Carolina one but in the aftermath
of the arraignment he did that [__]
he did that big uh you know I did
everything right and they indicted me
and not indicted in that uh a meeting
he pointed to Walt now to who was in the
room like he's not even hiding it he's
like very clearly and deliberately one
walking around with this code uh you
know this co-conspirator everywhere he
uh that he goes That's one two he shat
on the prosecutor that's Prosecuting him
and talked about his wife yeah his
wife's probably ugly so she had it
coming no I don't even know if she's
ugly or not but she uh she did the
Michelle Obama documentary he's like
Jack Smith he's a thug his wife is a
documentarian did shitty documentaries
on Michelle Obama they're woke folks
like
he's he's going the you know the
full-blown scorched Earth uh mode so
here's some highlights from the
indictment uh July 2021 Trump National
Golf Club in New Jersey during auto
recording meeting with a writer oh yeah
this guy was writing a a book about him
and record this conversation Trump
described and showed a plan of attack
that Trump said was prepared for him by
the Department of Defense Trump told the
individuals that the plan was highly
confidential in secret Trump also said
as president I could have Declassified
an N now I can't you know but this is
still a secret
yeah in August or September 2021 uh
Trump showed a representative of his
political action committee who did not
possess a security clearance classified
map related to a military operation and
told the representatives that he should
not be showing it to them and that they
should not get too close me that sounds
great man as a candidate for president
Trump made the following public
statements among others about classified
information Trump said in my
Administration I'm going to enforce all
laws concerning the protection of
classified information no one will be
above the law of course in the greatest
leopards ate my face he made laws
stricter uh in response to Hillary and
now he's being uh he's guilty of his own
[__] laws which he implemented those
laws why didn't he uh why isn't Hillary
in prison I'm just chilling in Cedar
Rapids she's actually the opposition I
don't really under I don't get why his
supporters don't notice that he was
President for four years and nothing
happened to Hillary like isn't that kind
of on him I'm I'm so bummed about me I'm
his supporter I'm the one who's upset I
was like Mr President I voted for you
illegally multiple times why didn't you
arrest Hillary Clinton uh Trump stated
in 2016 in my Administration I'm going
to enforce all laws concerning the
protection of classified information no
one will be above the law he stated we
also need to fight this battle by
collecting intelligence and then
protecting protecting our classified
secrets we can't have someone in the
Oval Office who doesn't understand the
meaning of the word confidential or
classified 2016 Trump said one of the
first things we must do is to enforce
all classification rules and to enforce
all laws relating to handling classified
information he stated also we also need
to we also need the best protection of
classified information he also said
service members here in North Carolina
have risked their lives to acquire
classified intelligence to protect our
country but I try to think but nothing
happens
um
so that's all pretty good stuff
pretty good the the right wing media is
coping hard yeah I'm sure Mike Lindell
had a uh
really normal oh my God I haven't I
haven't seen this this is exciting you
know our you know Mike always has the
spot yeah that's also Mike is talking to
Marjorie Taylor Green's Uh current
polycule boyfriend oh yeah right right
remember that's the that's the right
side broadcasting network guy in the
Newsmax Network guy
um who
it has sexual intercourse with Marjorie
Titan green when Kevin McCarthy's too
busy
but I bet Kevin lets uh him play with
the Nintendo switch love it just saying
here's what I think Rhonda Sanchez and
any others should just endorse our great
real president Donald Trump do it
tonight yeah but right now it's over
what this hoax of an indictment did was
just solidified Donald Trump as a
republican candidate for our for our
great uh for our presidents I've lost
everything dude Donald Trump I'm being
sued by Dominion I've lost everything
please Trump Donald Trump uh [__] uh
has his belt buckle unwind exposing his
diapers full of piss [__] and farts and
everyone's like and Mike Lindell will be
like well this moment is the moment that
Donald Trump showed that he's the real
president all right everyone needs to
get out of this race and it and endorse
him immediately I was worth I was worth
300 million dollars before I met Trump
now I'm about pretty close to living
back on the street I've started smoking
crack again Donald Trump's the greatest
president ever lived I will I will say
this all always like no disrespect to
addicts in recovery but like Mike
Lindell better with crack okay he sounds
like he's slurring his words a little
bit maybe he's been he's he just kind of
always sounds like that yeah I don't
know is that from the excessive use sure
he might have been yeah he might have
had some parts of his brain melt a
little bit but as you were saying Trump
uh takes I think what lawyers recommend
their clients always do to attack the
prosecutor publicly
um he also did this to the judge in his
first induction yeah he called the judge
yeah a lib or awoke he's alleged dude
he's [__] killing it that's what
you're supposed to do yeah my my uh
lawyer said actually I have done that
[__] what am I talking about yeah no it
wasn't a criminal case though maybe
that's definitely not the difference
I definitely had a lot to say about his
attorney
but it wasn't Criminal I don't know
maybe that makes a difference
yo what is this audio so uh like Hassan
said they're all [__] up except the
PBS one but the PBS one doesn't have a
[__] transcript that I can search for
uh to find all right all the key moments
yeah all right we can hear I'll just
listen I mean just just keep in mind
that this is what it sounded like all
over uh cable news like it's kind of
funny that this is what it sounded like
you know what I mean yeah only the best
deranged Jack Smith
I wonder what his name used to be Jack
Smith it's I'm so innocent what his name
used to be is he saying he's a Jew or
something Jack oh man sounds like a fake
name I actually agree with Trump here
yeah that is the most generic name ever
Jack Smith
he's not Mormon he looks like such an
old school like Mormon General agent Guy
totally like buy the book the entire way
I mean he's like he's a war crimes
prosecutor right and he actually and I'm
surprised Mr President why haven't you
used this line of attack it lives in the
Netherlands gay
yeah I mean Netherlands really what are
you biking uh I don't know he's in good
shape he's taking mushrooms and [__]
men yeah why are you in such good shape
are you what's up are you entertaining
men is that why
are you trying to look hot for men
just saying As Trump famously said
I did everything right and they indicted
me his record is absolutely atrocious
he does political hijabs he's okay
whatever I can barely understand what
you're saying dude shabibo had a take
actually shabibo conceded a little bit
Yeah because because well because he
wants the scientists to win he wants the
Santas right
absolutely in the pocket of DeSantis uh
here I'll tell you I'll tell you who the
[__] rhinos are okay Ben shibibo
number one uh he's in the pocket of Rob
DeSantis yeah uh uh Brian kill me that's
another one Brian kill me is one of them
kill me yeah no it's killed Brian I want
to kill myself it's not it's killing
kill me kill Mead
if you're hearing that then that's on
you okay I'm just saying his last name
is kill me Dr Phil what do you think
about that last name
we're disgusting I'm gonna kill you oh
my god Bill damn that's [__] up that
he said yo you might get copy strike for
his voice even he's like real we play
that all the time
um so Brian kill needs another one
um Sean Hannity's in the pocket of trump
as always he's uh you know he's totally
a trump guy
but most of these Republicans that are
currently on television talking a big
game about how like oh man we got to
defend Trump against these uh you know
these these false charges these
erroneous charges like their webinars of
the OJ secretly they're all like Tucker
Carlson Tucker Carlson's another
anti-trump guy
they all want him to go away because
they consider him to be volatile and and
uncontrollable for some reason and he's
a loser he lost a sleepy Joe and he's a
loser exactly so they're they're low-key
like oh thank God thank God these
[__] dumbass liberals in the in the
uh you know federal agencies finally got
their [__] together to [__] arrest
this guy Jesus
is one keeping helping hunk of a man
that's real here's babybo
everybody under the ton is now attacking
and attempting to prosecut and put in
jail Donald Trump and so Trump
predictably enough is like okay fine you
want to do it I'll do it too and this
will be the game from here on out
when the justice department gets reduced
to Pure politics you got a problem
now I hear people screaming all right
well but you just said that Trump may
have committed criminal activity here
the allegations against him are very
strong that's true the only way that you
actually restore The credibility of the
justice system is to have Republicans
for prosecutor Republicans and Democrats
prosecute democrats for the minute that
this now crosses the aisle we become so
politically polarized and partisan wait
pause it
dude first of all I don't think he knows
what that would do that would first of
all I mean that's a ridiculous [__]
take but even if let's say let's
entertain that for a second like even
Jim Comey is a republican you know how
many [__] federal agents are
Republicans idiot they would literally
every Republican would be going to jail
Democrats crime ridden like isn't he
just saying that would be legal for
Democrat people accountable what you're
just saying we need to hold our own
people accountable no no I think he was
he he's unironically saying that like
that will restore confidence in the
federal agencies if like we only let uh
Republicans I don't think that's what he
said no it is no it is
so stupid
system is to have Republicans for
prosecutor Republicans and Democrats
prosecute Democrats because the minute
that this now crosses the aisle would
become so politically polarized it
didn't actually mean that does he yeah I
think he just says [__] you know I don't
know I thought for sure he was like
metaphorically remember when the New
York Times wrote a puff piece about
bench if you're calling him the
Gladiator the intellectual Gladiator or
the right what was that
uh 2016 Barry White 2015 okay yeah
I've I've been holding that Grudge [__]
you New York Times I've been holding
that Grudge since then since that
[__] piece dropped it was like him
Jordan Peterson Joe Rogan Brett
Weinstein oh the infamous the
intellectual dark web the intellectual
dark trial yeah Barry Wise wrote that
[__] oh she's the worst I hate her so
much y'all there's a group of dudes out
there who are like yeah we're part of a
club called the intellectual dark web
there it is it was 2018. that uh this
legendary article dropped oh that's not
even that long ago
five years ago the basic line here is
that Republicans are just supposed to
accept that Republicans who are guilty
of crimes get indicted and Democrats are
guilty of crimes get slots on CNN and
MSNBC that is not a workable solution
he's annoying wait wait wait wait wait
remember when Oliver North
uh who was literally responsible or the
Fall Guy at least for Iran Contra was
propped up by Republican institutions I
believe he was the president of the NRA
for a brief moment like the idea that
Republicans do not celebrate [__]
criminals is ridiculous okay of course
they do
of course they do it's silly who what
whatever it's not even worth responding
didn't Chris Christie like he was like a
trump Ally until very recently or
whatever and wasn't
wasn't he like totally disgraced for
corruption in New Jersey Chris Christie
was disgraced for corruption for uh in
New Jersey yes dude he had some of the
best moments ever my favorite one of my
favorite moments he closed down a
[__] beach and then a helicopter saw
him chilling out on the beach with his
family they sent no plane to fly over
and with the [__] banner I mean it's
so iconic yeah Chris Christie is the
goat I love him to be honest though I
love big boys what's up of all the
candidates I do like him the best of the
Republicans yeah he's got he has got the
yabba dabba doo Charisma he does like no
one else has any [__] Riz in the
Republican party I mean I like him I
like him I love him I love a guy who's
willing to close down a whole Beach
version he closed the bridge too that's
actually another thing he did yeah the
bigger deal right yeah yeah
um but the reason he shut down this
whole beach by Governor's orders look at
this and he's just sitting there like
but the [__] eating grin like you got me
and when they asked him they they play
that it's they're just photos it's not
video oh they brought it up at a press
conference where they said Governor you
look to you seem to have gotten a lot of
sun this weekend and he went oh no I was
wearing a hat
[Applause]
look at how big his legs are I love him
I love him so much the beach down
Christy Under Fire after what did he
close the beach down for I think he
might have been like recovery from a
hurricane or something if I remember
correctly
[__] King dude
that's it you gotta flex your power you
gotta enjoy some privileges as governor
[Music]
yeah also shout out to mayor of
magaville these hot hot hot Maga rapper
dropped something fresh something spicy
in honor of the indictment called Trump
indictment fagadio blow and Stony
sorry Forgiato below his name is Joe
focha Joe no it's 4G like coronavirus
Auto blow like self suck right yeah 4G
auto blow auto fellatio Joe yeah all
right here we go
pretty vegan we're coming back on the
air at this hour with major developments
in the special counsel's investigation
don't be a rhino Ron this of course
would be the first president
on federal charges
[Music]
so so Mickey Mouse is there I guess
because of I'm not sure Disney's walk I
don't know get it that's interesting
because they don't like DeSantis now he
hates DeSantis but Disney hates the
santis but Disney's gone woke
but Disney's woke and and uh you know
transmogrifying your children
maybe they'll explain it maybe they'll
explain it nothing wrong
yes
[Music]
drop some sound drops of of him going I
did everything right and they indicted
me you got it bars Corruptions at an
all-time high
but not our president
[Music]
me
whatever it is yeah
wait is that are they still mad about
The Little Mermaid
maybe I think they I don't think so I
think they gave up on that they couldn't
even get mad at Spider-Man Spider-Man
has gone woke it's anti-white now all
the all the spider men and women are
like not white and because here's my
point
when you make the spider words yeah when
you make content that's like objectively
consumable and good it doesn't [__]
matter what the characters are what
their raises are all these racist idiots
can [__] cry and complain but no one
will give a [__] as long as the content
is good the only time that this
Narrative of like this is gone woke Styx
is when a show is actually bad it has
nothing to do with the characters being
like black or brown or white or anything
like that update I found this guy and
it's as good as you would think his name
is his Instagram is hot dude life this
is not him yes it is right no it's not
yes it is look at him no that's not him
wait what the [__] yes it is it's him
bro oh my God is he catfishing that's
him he's catfishing
go up to his like profile picture oh
this is old I think it's from uh oh my
God 11 weeks ago how long ago is that
bro he's literally catfishing years ago
bro I thought that was a different race
of God he does look what the [__] bro
what is happening his race man he's like
yo minorities are lame I'm gonna be
white now
yo what the [__] this makes it so this
is why he's hard to find
right bro that's a whole different dude
that's a different dude that's a whole
different race of dude yeah so here he
is this is after uh after he how did he
go from Dominican to Italian I don't
understand
he knows dude he knows it's hot dude bro
it's hot dude life his name is Jonathan
hogwood
love following page is called hot dude
life makes me feel very manly yeah I
want to be a hot dude like you brother
it's all about that hot dude life you
know what I'm saying okay bro listen I'm
Dominican how do I become White
I mean
Sammy Sosa
ask only dude I'm Jewish how do I become
white he goes that's not possible I
can't help you we don't know
he might be but these guys have uh
unique takes uh on on things like that
hi this is MLD interview with a man
empowerment now dude he looks so unwell
he's got the power tie though he just
looks unwell like I did everything right
and they indicted him this is looks like
the Photoshop you do of someone that you
want to look like they're like the
Tucker one from the subreddit this is
why here's the thing this is why
liposuction is not only incredibly
dangerous and you can [__] die I
don't recommend it but he is the reason
why you shouldn't do it because he's
yo-yo dieting right now he relapsed
because he didn't [__] actually die
it he just did the liposuction he lost
the weight and now he's getting it all
back damn this guy has been like hot
he's been a hot dude life in for a
minute but it's not working what dude
he's gone through every race bro this
dude is the Ariana Grande of dude
increase your success with women today
Modern Life dating.com yo he went from
Mexican yeah Dominican yeah back to
Italian like what is happening this dude
he thinks picking up women is like a
business uh dot business meme from stock
photo like what is this outfit I I think
that was probably a real estate photo
that he just reused yeah it kind of has
that vibe that would explain a lot dude
I love this guy I everything dude he
still has it in the header you don't
look like that you objectively don't
look like that that's crazy you look so
different than that that's a whole
different guy let me hear what he has to
say at work and I'm here today with a
very special message with you in regards
of the recent situations that have
happened to me I see this man uh oh he's
responding to the endure
this man has the billion dollar smile my
community and my image here on the
internet
as many of you know I was recently a
victim of a baseless Cyber attack from a
group of hate-filled individuals
this is his trailer bro this is your
trailer what the [__] you loser he did
everything right and they died my teeth
are so white
how could they think the ill of me I do
for the men in my community and the men
of my world
every single day since I started live
streaming and nobody cares bro literally
has four thousand of their lives of
manipulation have been disproven by me
and the men within my organization these
critics are now permanently silent uh oh
yeah I'm here earlier where's the bodies
yeah what the [__] did he do now I
didn't even know anything about this guy
now I'm like he's definitely did some
[__] yeah oh yeah this is a guy who
called me fat in my life my wife is
leaving me it's awesome I love you bro
you're the man keep it up hot dude life
man I'm dedicated I'm a student I live
in that hot dude life I want that hot
dude life
it was an unfounded Cyber attack guys
is that what he calls criticism now it
was an unfounded cyber that's awesome as
opposed to a founded Cyber attack what
the [__] what happened I don't know what
now I want to know I just now I have
more questions yeah let's see
um Tim Poole thinks this is a breakdown
political and social order of the United
States of course he does
stashed military Secrets my favorite
liberal prosecutors charged Trump with
37 felonies including 31 counts under
the Espionage Act of willful retention
of classified records
37 felonies
I mean this is this is breakdown of of
political and social order in the United
States
New York I can't remember how many was
that was that seven yeah something like
that but you know it
the timing on this is so I think this
show needs more guys literally the day
yeah
rock stars is that what you're saying
because that's all I'm seeing on screen
who are these they need why why are
there so many like unwashed sweaty
losers on on screen when when did he I
haven't watched him pool in a long time
so I I'm confused by this but they're
multiplying there was like one polish
guy I remember right who was like always
he was like the guy that was supposed to
make Temple look Smart in comparison and
then the long-haired like conspiracy guy
who like oftentimes says like weirdly
yeah this guy is close to Nazi [__] uh
he he came on he came in from what I've
been able to gather recently Tim's
audience hates that guy yeah I do too
like the con the comments are always
like he's such a [__] idiot why is he
on the show he really is yeah the Polish
guy no no the one that you were just
talking the one the long hair it is yeah
he has the mouse over right now okay he
just has like a very I mean I get this a
lot as well people say I like I'm very
smarmy he has that very same like smarmy
Cadence where it's like I know a lot I'm
out in the subject
well he had some really unhinged takes I
remember recently he had some take about
the Jews oh yeah he said he asked him
when we look back at this time period a
thousand years from now what do you
think will stand out and he goes I think
when we look back the Jews and everyone
else is going to realize how wrong they
were about Jesus Christ being their
savior that's the one thing we're going
to remember and Tim goes I think that
might be the craziest thing you've ever
said on the show
so he's like a firm believer that Jesus
Christ is coming back then that's
everything to him oh dude I love that
it's cool man I think yeah I think
adults should hallucinate more like I I
I'm a firm believer in that it's content
I think it's entertaining just don't
take it seriously yeah do it no do it in
a Hut in Peru honestly they're right
come back to reality there's a whole
bunch of examples but
I have to leave at like around 12 today
because shredder has a vet appointment
okay if you're only gonna watch one more
Giuliani
oh that's true let me read this and if
we have time we'll watch that so did you
see this disgusting Giuliani indictment
dropped he's also getting sued it's a
lot it's a civil lawsuit right this is
from the civil lawsuit this is this is
this is him being sued for uh sexual
assault it's a sexual dance this woman
was his quote assistant but she claims
she was hired basically to be his
on-call prostitute
right and she filmed a ton of [__] I
think just audio recording yeah yeah
this is all audio recording this is a
transcript so this is all real and just
imagine to see how sexy he looks when
he's saying that's what punished [__] no
I didn't because he's so physically vile
we have to look at a picture of him as
we read this so you know I know which
one you guys are not Tough Enough I know
which one just a bunch of [__] anal
sex handles those anal sex just imagine
everybody look at this and just imagine
this person is saying this to you bro I
can smell his breath bro it's like the
tonsil Stone moment like it's just so
gross he is so [__] vile dude
dude I feel like this guy makes Harvey
Weinstein look like Brad Pitt
okay here he goes here's some of the
Great Moments I'm gonna make it a little
painful
stick it up your ass
you're a [__] oh God you're a [__]
[__] you're my [__] I'm gonna get my
[__] in there be a [__] be Rudy [__]
anal sex Giuliani called Miss Dunphy a
[__]
Giuliani said oh this is my favorite
Line This is bars this is like the
weekend's new show that makes the
weekend's new show look PG-13 okay like
this is what kind of dirty talk you guys
should be doing out here okay I wanna
own you officially legally with a
document
that's all dude I'm sorry I can't go on
I just came okay I need to I am
uncontrollably horny now
I can't handle myself Ethan you gotta
take over I got you I I can't control
myself I lose control I think of you all
the time I'm unable to control it I'm
addicted
I can't think about you without getting
hard
oh my God is that he's so old is he
really just sexed up this vile he's
probably popping viagras every day oh
that was actually one of the things she
said that he's constantly taking Viagra
yeah well there you go because I can't
think about you without getting hard
well yeah you're on fire all the time
you probably can't think about a ham
sandwich without getting hard right even
when I think about how smart you are I
get hard
Julian has stated that he would get in
trouble with underage girls if they were
16 but look 20 yeah that's how that
works that's like literally what
happened
that's what that means you're right
it doesn't matter how old they look
another man who did everything right and
they indicted it's unbelievable oh then
this is the best part he says as
engaging and while engaging with sexual
contact with her he says to her I think
of you as my daughter
oh man
Donald Trump's Inner Circle they all
want to [__] their daughters
yeah sure enough he's got a daughter
this is awesome this meme I'm gonna make
it a little painful you're a [__]
[__] I'm gonna get my [__] in there be a
[__] Rudy get ready I want to own you
officially legally with a document even
when I think about how smart you are I
get hard I think of you as my daughter I
love the misogyny seeping through that
sentiment that is cool he goes like even
when I think about you being intelligent
I get hard like normally that wouldn't
do it for me because I would be upset
but now I think I I think what he meant
what's your argument is that when I'm
thinking about something non-sexual
I still get oh that's a more generous
interpretation I have to defend Rudy on
them
you made me defend this guy
I know damn you Hassan okay what was the
video you want me to watch you made me
oh I was just saying if we were gonna
wrap up uh
if there was just gonna be one more but
the the Rudy thing is a pretty powerful
thing to show me show me what did you
want to watch we have like 10 more
minutes I don't I'm looking if any of
these other Republican ones
Jimmy Lee posted this to Instagram holy
[__] he's been in the bathroom
that's crazy that is a huge violence I
want everyone I want everyone of the
foot soldiers to just picture that guy
having access to [__] attack plans
yeah because that is exactly the type of
guy who has access to the attack plans
under Donald Trump like he 100 showed at
the Jimmy Lee style [__]
well to be fair I feel like
well you would trust him Jimmy is
probably the most harmless of people you
would trust him with the attack plans
he's a good name but who's he gonna tell
you he means well he's a good dude or
Zach he probably tells that he tells
that he he can be trusted to his defense
he can be true security clearance oh
yeah just give him a security clearance
you don't need one the wait is there
something he wanted me to watch or no uh
if we're gonna watch one more thing it's
actually up at the very top in top of
the show hold on hold on hold on there's
another video I'd like is this real Kim
yeah I got this off of his name wait
what's going on with his hairline wait
why did he this is um
this was literally the photo he gave to
Newsmax for his interview wait wait and
then you got to see you got to see the
other photos
wait no but his hairline is yeah he
airbrushed the [__] out of it for for
Newsmax wait but he was hanging out with
party Donald below his hairline is like
glowing yeah that's literally the soft
round brush on Photoshop oh this is a
rare Trump pick oh my god oh they both
they both oh wow yeah yeah it's party
down there they both did the comb behind
like they they combed it back together
this is just before he showed him the
documents right there
Jersey Shore style you know that's
bedmister Jimmy did you know that that
Isis is planning an attack on our
nuclear systems
say nuclear Jimmy I got me Pirates
if you do some teeth work on me yeah
actually wait yeah he lives in Jersey so
you're right he was probably at the
Bedminster Club yeah I think I Believe
Jimmy belongs there he's a member yeah
all right what did you want to show me
Dan uh at the very top number three in
the top of the show section alert alert
Mike Lindell has a new plan to save the
country oh good oh I love that Hillary
Clinton broke the law hi and she didn't
get indicted
wait this isn't it uh
number three alert alert was it the
wrong link okay give me one second
because it's so funny I just I'll just
watch basically the wrong one in there
and so far
I did everything right and they indicted
me
the link that I just wrote Shredder is
looking at her like like [__] gonna
be cool right you guys are friends now
have they been together
[Music]
he's looking down like oh I want to be
down there so bad
all right here's outside alert no plan
that we have that I believe was given
from God that this new plan that we're
gonna announce and reveal on August 16th
and 17th will completely help save this
country it has never been done before
really it's never been talked about
before I compare that now so so
everybody you need to go to
lindalevent.com and you need to spread
the word about this event the only way
this doesn't work is that people don't
he was so good at making pillows wait
wasn't that that website Frank speech
wasn't that the one that like he has so
many websites now he he has Frank social
which is his social media uh website
which I am just him I have an account on
it's just his live stream uh no like
people like diamond and uh silk post
there well one of them is dead so it was
really weird I went on there and they
were they post they still promote the
show as if she's not dead like she's
still in all of them all right diamond
and silk I recall them
event in history
Hawaii where one third of the I think
one-thirds did they fill that up they
really promoting it like they're not
dead I I logged into uh to uh Frank
social and this was on my default
timeline they she died dude yeah this
was posted uh yesterday jeez
we need to help everybody watching this
because when this happens everyone's
gonna go on August 18th go wow this is
gonna work it's beautiful he didn't say
what it is election crime Bureau Summit
dude he's just saying be there everybody
knows what it is yeah so I'm gonna be
keeping a close eye on this uh the the
link to the website is right below there
Lindell event election crime Bureau yeah
meanwhile as he's still trying to dis or
prove that the election was stolen he
owes that guy five million dollars one
proved illegally and was ruled by a
judge that he did that yeah but the
judge was also under uh mind control by
the pedophile FBI okay fair enough uh
who's owned there one thing I will say
one final note I guess I'll uh end this
with wait is that right now
our nation um without the Republican
party's instruments of astroturfing uh
they're they're like actual public
events are oftentimes just Duds with the
with the notable exception of like uh
you know School trans Panic stuff like
that which the Republican party is still
uh pushes for the Q Anon guys and all
these other like [__] weird like save
the children guys or all the other like
we got to save Donald Trump guys okay
calm down all the others we got to save
Donald Trump from this arraignment guys
they're they're unfortunately not all
that big in numbers like there is the
very real fear of January 6th style
prosecution coming their way uh and that
I think has really put a dent in the
movement overall okay hold on I'm sorry
this is pretty compelling stuff right
here do you see the files has been taken
to expose the truth I just want to point
that out
all right wait actually this is right
here
let's hear what he has to say here I
love this part okay
suppose the truth let's take their
country how are we gonna do it let's use
it with computers so we don't even have
to fire a shot dude
it's kind of similar to the other guy
who uh had an unfounded Cyber attack or
whatever I'm gonna let her I'm gonna let
her loose oh here we go
all right Ethan you you gotta go
um it reminds me there's this one scene
from Ali G he goes to this inventor and
he goes with just a blank skateboard
deck and he goes here's my idea hovering
skateboards like from Back to the Future
he goes okay let's just Escape deck he
goes no no
I come with the idea you do the science
it's just [__] giving that yeah how
do we do it
computers no Mike Lindell is a cartoon
character he's the ideas guy and you
guys are [__] on him for you know
being
uh the greatest Midwestern American 300
million dollars he was worth he reminds
me so much of uh Tim heidecker's
character that's it on Cinema thousand
it's the it's the same person
well shout out Mike Lindell he did
everything right and they indicted him
I'm Mike Lindell ladies and gentlemen
I'll tell you what Donald Trump is the
most innocent man in America
[Music]
all right I was told you have to leave
at 12 today we're a few minutes past 12.
all right guys thanks for being here
thank you Hassan we will not be here
next week leftovers will not be here
next week because Hassan actually we
should say more than that this is the
last leftovers for a few weeks because
oh [__] we are going on vacation holy
[__] after next week so Hassan's gone
next week made our live shows next week
it sure is holy man I know God damn I've
been trying to put the what is this
vacation what is this vacation nonsense
so the next week you're gone and then
we're gone for like two weeks right okay
that's correct so we won't see you back
season three
[Applause]
so much content politics is so bad I
love it I love it I love it so uh okay
well so we'll see in a little bit
someone have fun in Japan
and uh we'll see everybody tomorrow for
Friday after dark episode that's I'm
planning on it being good it's gonna be
a good episode unlike today's episode
[Music]
yeah
all right